i mean you said that that lawsuit kind
of
broke you right so i can only imagine
that getting on the other side of that
like the
animosity you might have towards rough
riders in general like
who told you that no i'm saying that you
you said that after you got
released that going through and hiring
lawyers and stuff you ended up like
kind of broke end up i ended up being
broke i ended up being uh homeless you
had to go back to the streets
but i had to go back to the streets and
restart my career
so you ended up homeless after rough
riders yeah yeah
yeah i i was i i was actually homeless
while i was still on rough riders
you were homeless so so explain to me
being homeless like wouldn't you say
homeless what does that mean i have a
place to stay
so you actually were definitively
homeless while still being on rough ride
yes
so i started my company and just kept
building for the past 10 years
so did dny know you were homeless or was
that something where it was like it was
just that the relationship
was so sour i don't know like once i
left rough riders i focused on hood
environment
right damn
for people watching this man that that's
that's a low that is hard to come out of
being homeless
right especially being drag on from
rough riders
hitting homelessness having to get back
to the streets to get your money up
the perseverance that that takes the
dedication the like mental fortitude
that that takes to not let that [ __ ]
break you got to be crazy man
yeah yeah i mean you know
at the end of the day i don't really
like rely too much
on the people that's down here on this
earth with me you phone say i rely on
god god got me
you know i mean so you know i'm here on
the strength
of god i am living proof that
god will help you if you ask him you
know i'm saying if you pray if you
prayed up
if you keep yourself within the bubble
of prayer
then god will be there for you your
franchisee and and
and and even for the people that don't
pray but just believe
in god your father said god got them too
you know what i'm saying so my thing was
just
let me like once i did that i just focus
on my
company and then the street started
catching on to it so i just stayed
focused on that how long was that period
of time that you were actually homeless
like before you got to play like how
long
like how long was that maybe like a
year and a half two years or something
like that wow
damn man well look you came a long way
bro and uh
as listen you're a part of history
yes sir you are a part of history man
never denying that